le ring c'est à coups de signatures que
le nouveau président condé faire les
politiques de son prédécesseur il
multiplie les décrets présidentiels sur
la santé et facilitent l'accès aux soins
pour tous les américains et ramène la
loi sur les soins abordables de l'ancien
président barack obama sur le climat
aussi le ton tranche et il est suivi par
des actions un moratoire sur les forages
d'hydrocarbures sur les terres et eaux
fédérales élimination des subventions
profitant à l'industrie des combustibles
et investissements dans les énergies
renouvelables la lutte contre les
changements climatiques sera une
priorité nationale en matière de
sécurité dit le président
c'est une menace existentielle dit il et
annonce un sommet de la terre le 22
avril prochain système économe sur
l'équité raciale il c'est une quatre
décrets en début de semaine pour mettre
fin aux discriminations et revient sur
la mort de john floyd
ces huit minutes 46 sont ouvert les yeux
de l'amérique dit il des choses doivent
changer
en matière de logement il signait un
décret qui renforce les politiques
antidiscriminatoires quant aux
incarcération il met fin aux contrats du
gouvernement fédéral avec les prisons
privées
bref un nouveau shérif est en ville et
ils comptent destitué l'ancien tout ceci
sur fond de pandémie de crise économique
le pays a connu sa pire année depuis la
fin de la seconde guerre mondiale
[Musique]
en emploi un million de chômeurs juste
en une semaine
joes hayden espère que son plan
d'urgence de 1900 milliards de dollars
sera adoptée par le congrès olympien
mais pour le moment le congrès est
divisée tendu et fait face à une élue
pro trompe encombrants l'ennemi est
parmi nous lance nenci pelosi faisant 46
ans marguerite et le green siège à la
chambre depuis le 3 janvier
elle soutient la mouvance qu un homme et
a déjà écrit que plusieurs fusillades
dans les écoles n'étaient que des mises
en scène
l'ombre de l'ancien président roh
toujours jeudi dans notre chambre
recevait dans sa résidence en floride
kevin mccarthy le chef des républicains
à la chambre des représentants son appui
pour les prochaines élections demeurent
précieux mais rien pour perturber joe
biden qui signera d'autres décrets
présidentiels la semaine prochaine
notamment sur la réunification des
familles et des enfants migrants et si
elle est modelée guerguisse radio-canada
washington